"POPCOPY" EMPLOYEE
TRAINING FILM
WITH YOUR HOST,
RALPH HENDERSON.
HELLO,
I'M RALPH HENDERSON.
AND IF YOU'RE WATCHING
THIS VIDEO,
THAT MEANS YOU'VE
JUST BEEN HIRED TO WORK HERE
AT "POPULAR COPY".
ME AND MY FRIENDS ARE
GONNA SHOW YOU THE BASICS
OF WHAT IT'S LIKE
TO WORK HERE.
YOU GUYS READY ?
YEAH !
GREAT.
FIRST OF ALL,
NEVER SHOW UP ON TIME,
AND IF A SUPERVISOR HAPPENS
TO ASK YOU WHERE YOU WERE,
YOUR RESPONSE SHOULD
SOUND SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
MANUEL,
WHY WERE YOU LATE ?
MAN, I GOT HERE
WHEN I COULD !
SHIT, YOU'RE NOT
MY FUCKING MOMS !
( chuckles )
PERFECT !
OCCASIONALLY,
YOU MAY GET SNAGGED
BY ONE OF THESE
CUSTOMER PEOPLE.
JUST REMEMBER, YOUR JOB
IS TO FRUSTRATE THEM
AND MAKE THEM FEEL UNWANTED.
IF YOU CAN,
WRAP UP A STORY
THAT WILL MAKE THEM FEEL
UNCOMFORTABLE.
FOR INSTANCE...
YOU UNDERSTAND WHAT
I'M SAYING, RIGHT ?
I MEAN, YOU KNOW
MY REPUTATION.
I DON'T GIVE A FUCK,
I'LL GO TO RIKERS
FOR THREE OR FOUR YEARS
JUST TO PROVE MY POINT,
I DON'T PLAY THAT SHIT.
CAN I HELP YOU ?
OR...
HELL, YEAH, I SUCK TOES !
GOOD AFTERNOON,
WELCOME TO "POPCOPY",
CAN I HELP YOU ?
OR...
( man )
WHAT'S WRONG ?
MY BUTT IS ITCHIN' LIKE CRAZY,
AND I TOOK A SHOWER.
CAN I HELP YOU ?
IF A CUSTOMER
HAS A COMPUTER DISK,
THEN LOOK AT IT AND TELL THEM
IT'S THE WRONG FORMAT.
IF THEY USE APPLE,
TELL THEM WE'RE P.C.
IF THEY USE P.C., TELL THEM
WE'RE APPLE.
AND IF THEY GOT BOTH,
THEN TELL THEM WE USE LINUX.
AND IF THEY GOT THAT, TELL THEM
THE COMPUTERS ARE DOWN.
THEY SHOULD BE, ANYHOW.
YOU SEE, THE WHOLE SYSTEM
ACTUALLY WENT DOWN.
IT'S GONNA BE SHUT DOWN
FOR A COUPLE HOURS.
HOURS ?
IT HAPPENS.
THE WHOLE SYSTEM ?
BUT THIS IS A BIG PLACE,
HOW CAN--
LISTEN, SISTER,
I GOTTA GO TAKE A SHIT.
I DON'T BELIEVE
HE SAID THAT !
SHOULD A CUSTOMER GET ALL UPPITY
AND ASK TO SPEAK TO A MANAGER,
THEN TELL THEM,
"GUESS WHAT ?
I AM THE MANAGER."
I WANNA SEE THE MANAGER.
NO, SEE,
I AM THE MANAGER.
YOU ARE THE MANAGER ?
THAT'S RIGHT,
MY FRIEND.
I'M THE ONLY MANAGER HERE.
UNLESS YOU WANT TO TALK
TO THE "POPCOPY" PRESIDENT
AND I DON'T KNOW HIM, YOU MIGHT
COULD HELP ME OUT WITH THAT.
I MEAN, REALLY GET
IN THEIR FACE ABOUT IT.
I WANNA SEE
YOUR MANAGER !
GUESS WHAT, NIGGA ?
I AM YOUR MANAGER,
WHAT'S UP ?
YOU'RE THE MANAGER ?!
THAT'S RIGHT,
HOW MAY I HELP YOU ?
YOU DONE, THAT'S IT.
YOUR JOB IS DONE, NIGGA,
GET OUT !
I'LL SEE YOU LATER--
WHAT ARE YOU
TALKING ABOUT ?!
Y'KNOW, A LOT OF PEOPLE
ASK, "WHY ?"
"WHY TREAT
THE CUSTOMER THIS WAY ?"
WHY ?
'CAUSE FUCK 'EM,
THAT'S WHY.
BATHROOM UPKEEP IS IMPORTANT
TO US HERE AT "POPCOPY".
BE SURE TO SPRAY CHOCOLATE SAUCE
ON THE WALL NEAR THE TOILET
TO GIVE THE APPEARANCE
OF ERRANT FECES.
THIS WILL ENSURE THAT ANY
CUSTOMER WHO USES OUR RESTROOM
WILL NEVER, EVER RETURN
TO ONE OF OUR STORES.
WE ASK THAT YOU SIGN A SHEET
TO VERIFY THIS GETS DONE
ONCE AN HOUR,
24 TIMES A DAY.
UH-OH, TONY,
YOU MISSED A SPOT.
WHOA...
NOW THAT LOOKS POOPY.
I HOPE YOU FOUND
THIS TAPE INFORMATIVE.
AND SHOULD YOU EVER
DOUBT YOURSELF
AND CONSIDER TREATING
A CUSTOMER WITH RESPECT,
JUST REMEMBER THIS:
YOU GRADUATED FROM
GRADE SCHOOL,
AND YOU DON'T HAVE TO
TAKE SHIT FROM ANYONE.
WELCOME TO THE "POPCOPY" FAMILY,
AND CONGRATULATIONS.
WHOOP HIS ASS,
WHOOP HIS ASS !
WHOOP HIS
ASS !
♪ "POPCOPY" ♪♪